told me I couldn't work because I'm
growing out my hair yep that's what you
said so here we go you like this [ __ ]
look a [ __ ] idiot Oh Oh what is going
on you crusty face mother now I don't
know about you but when I work out I
sweat and not just when it comes to
working out but in general when you're
fat your sweats a lot
you ever get that weird sweat in between
your boobs you know that you know right
here in between the flat but he's just
like just me fellas ladies know what God
and you know what just not fair because
not only do I sweat from just about
anything I sweat when I sweat baking
grease comes out every time I walk out
it smell like Korean barbecue and Shane
you have any idea how hard it is to talk
to people when you constantly sweat they
always think you're lying about [ __ ] hey
it's not my fault my sweat glands I want
to eat you like every single girl I
talked to assumed that I was cheating on
them because I had nervous sweats and I
don't cheat
maybe you should stop yelling me I'm
sensitive [ __ ] do not cheat now huh get
out my legs and my ball set or sword
24/7 I can't even cheat on you even if I
vomit you ain't nobody want to be with
somebody they look like Bambi walking on
ice half the time I like feel like
chopping noodles like I just know not a
walk you know what I hate after a leg
day when you just chilling and there's
suddenly your lady just [ __ ] gives a
hug because you already know when you
get a leg cramp right when you about to
fall you make that one weird ass noise
but anyways you to progress on my
workout suck it all honestly diving has
been rough for me like when I first
started this out I was pretty strict on
a very specific diet but now I am eating
you know what I want here there so
progress is still there I have lost a
couple of pounds since the last video
but it's not going as fast as I wanted
to
whatever ate about the numbers got a
healthier lifestyle so because I am
progressing I'm not hating on it I just
[ __ ] hate this hair already four
people have assumed that I can't speak
English [ __ ] you
but all the triple-s turning I have seen
a couple videos that people have made
and i'ma tell you something right now
very proud of you I'm there
to you 100% I am watching your videos
when I can but of course I can't go
ahead and comment on all of them because
you know I got a [ __ ] life I gotta
make a living uh [ __ ] eat but you have
triple F back the way I've been
progressing I will be getting rid of
this mop soon enough
yes kpop aspire so once again remember
life is always what you make it but it's
up to you to take what you deserve
let's go for broke Oh what is going on
YouTube that concludes another episode
of triple F that I really you know say
something profound on this one I don't
know I just wanted to mention that I
hate sweating and that's what I do when
I work out happens all the time
but yes this air this [ __ ] hair these
another suck in hey we'll be going soon
because I determined to get rid of this
and I cannot cut it unless I lose the
weight because I'm a man of my word and
I do have a wedding coming up so I don't
want to look like this at the wedding
what's up with this hair it looks like
that automatic we have a lisp it [ __ ]
will happen what song game what's your
name this is Topher the Gopher for
square feet I know y'all like this I
know y'all wanna cop this cuz it looks
good look good it's my [ __ ] remember to
copy gear and go for broke apparel calm
and yes all the new stuff is on sale for
the first two weeks yes hot new releases
always coming at you and yes we all know
that you want it and every time it goes
out you get mad don't get mad don't get
mad but I don't next on triple FF your
ego there's a Sunday upload and yes if
you guys want to follow me I do have an
Instagram and I do have a Twitter and a
Facebook fan page make sure you click
and go to there all that [ __ ] is all
linked up well not linked up but you can
see the [ __ ] because you know you two
wanted to do that wish they would wish
you would you up honey I bet haha yeah
you have any idea how hard it is to talk
hundred East Harley's whatever I do
whatever many and I might want to be
don't laugh at your own jokes that's
unprofessional I'm kidding you cheating
on you cheating on you it's not even
work come on David focus what can you do
this I'm sensitive today was probably
focus don't cry wipe it away
oh god was I supposed to say okay focus
read the line read the line